[Music]
how many countries are in South America
12 name them all in alphabetical order
Argentina Bolivia Brazil Chile Colombia
Ecuador Guyana Paraguay Peru Suriname
Uruguay and Venezuela non sovereign
territories that would include the
Falkland Islands and French Guinea raw
at French Guiana
you mean the Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance Act of 1978 a little I
guess great what are the five provisions
of FISA the law provides procedures for
the collection of electronic
surveillance physical searches pin
registers and trap-and-trace devices for
foreign intelligence purposes access to
certain relevant business records and a
reporting requirement for oversight okay
can you please dunk this basketball from
an NBA regulation height hoop I don't
think so what's two times two four
what's four times four sixteen what 16
times 16 256 what's 256 x 256 65,536
what 65,536 times 65,536 four billion
two hundred nine to four million nine
hundred six to seven thousand two
hundred ninety-six correct why was
Andrew Johnson impeached well President
Johnson clashed with reconstruction
efforts to give rights to free slaves
after the Civil War and as a result was
charged with high crimes and
misdemeanors was he removed from office
he was acquitted by a Senate vote of 35
to 19 one vote short of the two-thirds
needed to convict was there a lasting
impact yeah as a result of his
impeachment Congress introduced the
tenure of office act to restrict the
president's ability to fire cabinet
members and one was a first dick for the
first wife dick for what's a dick for
you